what did it take to get the majority of
the American public behind President
Obama new military intervention in Iraq
yes last week Obama authorized targeted
airstrikes against the Islamic state
group in northern Iraq and a yougov poll
found that fifty-eight percent of
americans support the air strikes in
fact the support is even equal among
Democrats and Republicans and we know
how rare that is but let's take a step
back what are the reasons Obama's given
for intervening well he says it's to
prevent is fighters from wiping out
Yazidis a religious minority and to
protect US personnel in the city of
Erbil Obama called his aerial campaign
in Iraq a quote long-term project and
made a moral argument for intervening
when we have the unique capabilities to
help avert a massacre and i believe the
United States of America cannot turn a
blind eye but is this mission purely
humanitarian or are there economic
interests at play here as some have been
quick to point out courtesy rock in
addition to being home to an American
consulate is the most stable
oil-producing region in the country in
fact major oil wells are operated there
by American companies like exxon mobil
and chevron and the u.s. certainly
doesn't want to see that in anyone
else's hands but whatever the reasons
for the airstrikes in Iraq and despite
the support for them there has been some
dissent Republican senator Ted Cruz and
Democratic senator Tim Kaine both say
Obama should seek Congress's approval
before once again deepening the US
military involvement in Iraq because
after all the Constitution says he has
to Senator Caine specifically said that
he wanted the objectives to be made
clear to Congress the American people
and our men and women in uniform many
are wondering when is it okay for the
u.s. to intervene militarily and why has
US military intervention taken place in
some regions but not in others former
congressman Ron Paul argued this week
that intervention hasn't always been a
solution nor will it be this time I
think it's a little bit late to try to
salvage all the mistakes that we've made
for the past 24 years I've been opposed
to going into Iraq all the way back to
the beginning in 1990 because I believe
in non-intervention that we should mind
our own business and it never works out
very well do you agree or do you think
Obama made the right call and is
the US ever really going to leave Iraq
let us know what you think by tweeting
us at aj+